yesterday the sec chairman gary ginsler
was asked whether he or the sec had
plans to ban bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
and as you would expect gary ginsler
said no now this is really important
because last week we saw the federal
reserve chairman jerome powell asked the
same exact question do you have plans to
ban bitcoin or cryptocurrencies the
answer was no so we now have the federal
reserve chairman saying no they do not
plan to ban bitcoin we also now have the
sec chairman saying that they will not
ban bitcoin or cryptocurrencies either
this is
two two different points here one they
don't have the power to ban it the sec
has no right to oversee or ban assets
that are not considered securities also
the federal reserve is not in the
business of banning assets or banning
ownership of these types of financial
products
congress however does have that ability
so congress could
theoretically vote to actually ban
ownership of bitcoin in america now i
highly doubt that is going to happen we
have multiple congress people who
actually own bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
they understand that this is good for
their constituents there's tens of
millions of americans that own these
assets there has been hundreds of
thousands of jobs either directly or
indirectly created in this industry
there's trillions of economic value that
has been created by the industry and so
if you were to
come together and try to be adversarial
towards these assets it would likely
lead to a massive backlash from the
people it's very hard for politicians to
go against the will of the people and
the people want bitcoin and
cryptocurrency so it's great to see the
sec chairman saying this now when you
get regulatory clarity it's not full
clarity but it's a step in the right
direction when you get that all of a
sudden it gives the green light wall
street institutions individuals large
family offices everywhere across the
board people see something bullish like
that what do they do they go and they
buy a little more so it's not surprising
this morning that we saw bitcoin explode
upwards over 54 000
when we look at the charts we can see
bitcoin up over seven percent this
morning every other asset basically
doesn't matter they barely move compared
to bitcoin there is no volatility in
these other assets you've got boomers on
wall street who are celebrating a 0.96
percent move in the stock market today
nobody cares if you can't move with true
volatility no one who is young is going
to pay attention whether you like it or
not if we then go and we look at the
bitcoin stats themselves we can see that
bitcoin has officially regained the
status of being a trillion dollar asset
that means that the bitcoin network
which was created and launched january
3rd 2009 has now grown
to one trillion dollars in market cap
for only 12 years of existence that is
absolutely incredible almost 90 percent
of the bitcoin is in circulation and
then again remember what i told you last
week
20 billion dollars of on-chain
settlement volume has only happened a
handful of times about seven eight
different times yesterday in the last 24
hours
21.6 billion dollars of settlement
volume occurred on chain not on the
exchanges actually on chain one of the
biggest days one of the top 10 days ever
for bitcoin settlement on chain people
are using this as a medium of exchange
regardless of what the mainstream media
or anybody else says the real exchange
volume over 10 billion dollars huge huge
numbers and then yesterday miners in the
last 24 hours made almost 50 million
dollars from that bitcoin block reward
not including transaction fees the
global revenue over the last 24 hours
for bitcoin miners was close to 50
million dollars the economic incentive
of this system is taking over and we are
watching an absolute fomo you've never
seen fomo like q4 bitcoin bull run fomo
and we are just entering it today if we
go ahead and we look at the actual asset
compared to the s p 500 in gold you can
see that bitcoin is up
408 percent over the last year these are
video game numbers if you go all the way
back to march of 2020 we kept telling
you that this was going to happen you
can't print trillions of dollars scare
investors into believing inflation is
coming and have them run for inflation
hedge assets and they happen to pile
into an asset that has a fixed supply of
course it is going to increase in value
significantly so 400 plus percent
increase in the last one year gold down
7
gold has failed as an inflation hedge
asset there is not a young person who is
trying to buy gold they are dumping gold
and they are buying bitcoin or other
assets and then you have the s p 500 up
28 over the last year if you go all the
way down to the 10 year yes
bang bang over 1 million percent
increase in the bitcoin price over the
last 10 years
literally it's like asking a second
grader how much did it go up and they're
like one million percent yes it is
insane now if we go ahead and we look at
bitcoin gold s p 500 nasdaq and the
treasuries we can see them side by side
the roi of bitcoin of course check mark
it's beating everything but the compound
annual growth rate is now 158
over the last 10 years every year 158
compounded for a decade is unheard of
absolutely insane and so no matter what
statistic you look at whether it is how
many people are on the network how many
nodes are on the network how much mining
hashrate is on the network what is the
actual activity of those that are buying
or selling on the network everything is
bullish it looks like a big green light
for q4 bull run to commence this is the
second leg of the bull market we've had
this happen time and time again in bull
markets and so
the history is not a predictor of the
future
but damned is it rhyming now of course
this doesn't go unnoticed by people on
the internet and i just had to call out
the fact that jack dorsey the leader of
twitter and the leader of square he hit
us with a one t tweet today
well i don't know what jack was talking
about but it's probably not a
coincidence that when it hits a trillion
he then tweeted one t
and so no matter who you are everyone
really respects jack he's not seen as
some bitcoin ludite on the internet but
they are all watching it is so strong of
an economic incentive to participate and
as it goes up you take the social
consensus of i have to tweet about it
then if we look at charlie lowe have we
ever decided how to say his name charlie
bolillo who is fantastic on twitter he
has bitcoin rises to the highest level
since may it's up 88
from the low in june if you were buying
bitcoin in june you're up 88
absolutely stunning to see in a three or
four month period then if we continue on
the young wizard will clemente yesterday
hitting us with the long-term holder
supply shock has reached all-time highs
if you remember that green
bar across the top there every time that
we have entered into that long-term
holder supply reaching that green bar
what we have seen is a very very rapid
price appreciation afterwards again
history is not a predictor of the future
but the on-chain metric of long-term
holder supply is suggesting that you
should buckle up now if we then go and
we look well what are the miners doing
after a few weeks of selling
will points out that the miners have
actually started to accumulate again and
so when we look at this minor buying
you can see that price usually
appreciates following the start of minor
accumulation and so every single
statistic that we are looking at is
showing that there is bullish tailwinds
to this asset but my favorite chart my
favorite metric that anyone has pointed
out dylan leclair coming off the top
rope 360 windmill dunking saying never
in the history of bitcoin network has
this large a percentage of the
circulating supply been held for over
three months
85
of all bitcoin in circulation has not
moved in 90 days
that is insane the supply squeeze is
definitely underway dylan and so when
you start to look at the fact that 85 of
bitcoin has not moved in 90 days
regardless of price appreciation any
sort of volatility and then on top of
that
the chinese ban
two transactions occurred during that
time period as well it didn't shake
anyone out bitcoin holders are here to
stay and so demand increases going in to
q4 i expect price to appreciate very
very rapidly